dans le domaine agricole les éleveurs de
bovvin s'inquièent du risque de
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle maladie en
Touren on l'appelle couramment le covid
de la vache il s'agit de la MHE maladie
hémorragique
épisootique arrivée en France en
septembre elle ne transmet elle ne se
transmet pas à l'homme mais au beau
viidé via des piqûes de moucheron
conséquence des animaux affaiblis et une
diminution de leur rendement en lait 56
communes touronggel ont déjà été
intégrées dans le périmètre de
surveillance de la maladie et déjà les
éleveurs sont vigilants pour détecter
les premiers symptômes Lucas Chopin et
Roméo
marm cet animal là fait partie des
animaux qu'on avait sélectionné dans
notre troupeau donc pour aller la
présenter à fermeexo la faire découvrir
au grand public Denis Raguin est éleveur
de vaches laitières et cette année il a
fait le choix de ne pas présenter de
bêtes à fermeexo en cause la maladie
épisotique hémorragique dont il souhaite
préserver les animaux du département en
effet ce virus transmis par des
moucherons et surnommé le covid de la
vache est aux portes de la Touren le
premier risque c'est un risque de baisse
de production donc un risque économique
hein avant tout et des animaux donc qui
qui sont fatigués dans les cas vraiment
les plus sérieux où on a tardé à
détecter la maladie on peut arriver à la
mort des animaux tout ce qu'on espère
c'est avoir du froid hein puisqu'on
arrive à la saison de l'hiver et ce qui
permettrait de limiter cette propagation
ce serait le l'arrivée des des premiers
froids si le virus ne provoque la mort
de l'animal que dans 1 à 2 % des cas il
reste important de surveiller le moindre
symptôme de fatigue notamment lors de la
traite on a des symptômes respiratoires
du jetage qu'on appelle c'està-dire le
des sécrétions qui sortent des narines
on a des conjonctivites on a aussi des
boîteries parce que ça peut toucher
aussi les membres donc des ulcérations
des mamelles aussi sur les vaches
laitières donc c'est assez divers quand
même pour le moment il y a aucun cas de
transmission à l'homme ou dans d'autres
espèce animales comme les chiens les
chats les éleveurs bovins sont désormais
appelés à la plus grande vigilance à les
déplacements de vaches et a signalé tout
cas suspect à un
vétérinaire